to understand ratios you just need to
understand this simple story Gaurav and
J used to receive chocolates from a
mysterious magic hand every day but the
magic hand was a little biased to us J
every time it gave two chocolates to
Gaurav it gave three - J - to Gaurav and
three to J nobody knew why of course J
did not complain so the ratio of the
number of chocolates Gaurav got to the
number of chocolates J got is written as
2 : 3 or 2/3 this can be read as 2 is to
3 we are basically comparing the number
of chocolates God of God to the number
of chocolates J got this went on for
quite a few days so every time the magic
hand gave two chocolates to Gaurav it
gave 3 chocolates - J now let's count
the total number of chocolates
each of them have Gaurav has 4 and J has
6 the ratio now becomes 4 by 6 the magic
hand again gives God of 2 chocolates and
j-3 chocolates now the total number of
chocolates with Gaurav is 6 and the
total number of chocolates with J is 9
so the ratio becomes 6 by 9 both these
ratios when simplified will give us 2 by
3 in every case the ratio has remained
the same what does this mean if we
multiply 2 with 2 and 3 also with 2 we
get 4 by 6 if we multiply 2 with 3 and 3
with 3 we will get 6 by 9 and similarly
if you multiply 2 with 4 and 3 with 4 we
will get 8 by 12 which is again
equivalent to 2 by 3 so all the three
ratios are equal to 2 by 3 what does all
this mean it means that if the ratio of
two quantities is 2 by 3 then the
quantities will be multiples of 2 and
multiples of 3 respectively
and not necessarily just two and three a
few students have this confusion that
the ratio of two by three will mean
Gaurav has just two chocolates and
judges three chocolates if the ratio is
2 by 3 then the quantities will be in
the form of 2x and 3x where 2x and 3x
are multiples of 2 and 3 so ratio is
basically a comparison of quantities but
there is a bit more to comparison of
quantities we see that next